[Music]
it'd be teased social study your quick
catch up on what's the labs are posting
online I had a dream we were she
finished Junaid producer kygo posted
that first look of his new music video
with Selena Gomez for their song it
ain't me to Instagram while Drake took
to social media Friday to shut down
quote fake media after reports world
earlier this month that he asked a
Muslim woman to remove her head jab at
his concert in London writing in part I
make a point every night to end my shows
on tones of unity and love I would never
make a disrespectful comment like that
in my life
meanwhile Kourtney Kardashian spent her
Friday night in with daughter Penelope
posting this pic of the pair eating
chips and watching TV in bed Vin Diesel
took to the gram to gush over his xxx
co-star Nina Dobrev posting this pic and
sweetly captioning it you can't help but
love her Thank You Nina for being a
baller on and off screen we've been
friends for a while since splitting from
boyfriend Chris Evans Jenny slate has
been spending time with her gal pals she
shared this pic with friends Zoe Kazan
at the Madewell intimates launch event
in Los Angeles writing love was in the
air for me and my poodle
[Music]